this is one of those things where it
came into my life and there's nothing
you can do about it so you just start to
figure out like okay well how can I
learn from this experience and how can I
get through it in a way that doesn't
completely deplete me from who I am
so I started doing chemo and
chemotherapy was fine to the point where
let's pause for a second yeah go for it
I mean here's what's crazy how relieved
are you first of all because are you
thinking the entire time this is a death
sentence 100 because my body I have
dealt with Healthcare issues my entire
life I have one of the worst cases of
eczema you could imagine where at
doctors my whole life have just looked
at me and said I'm sorry
yeah and I'm like you're a I don't need
your sympathy here man like I need you
to fix me
the Honeydew with Ryan sickler